this week on brian ross investigates
new details on the summer camp once
considered one of the finest in the
country
it was this idyllic place where i could
be myself
folk songs campfires and allegations of
a dangerous cycle of sexual abuse and
cover-up i believe we have 20
clients who are now suing are based upon
their sexual assaults at the camp camp
leaders have promised a full
investigation but now two former staff
members are coming forward tonight to
call that into question
i noticed the very toxic pattern of
talking to the families and saying this
is you know one-off occurrence when in
fact it was happening
you know every summer there was a lack
of urgency
to really find out the truth
plus that family tragedy in south
carolina everyone's talking about
a lawyer accused of hiring a hitman to
kill him so that his son could get 10
million dollars it happened three months
after his wife and son were murdered in
shootings that remain unsolved we'll get
the latest from a leading reporter and
law and crimes julie render
and this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
choices made by the editors of meteorite
joe cut them off please cut them off now
cut them off now
you're not going to blame this on
president trump on my show
from the law and crime trial network
this is brian ross
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross and we
begin tonight with new details on the
sexual abuse scandal involving a
well-known summer camp that families for
generations have been sending their
children
for generations american families sent
their children to this summer camp folk
songs campfires camaraderie in the
mountains of southern virginia
as a teen it was this idyllic place
where i could be myself i felt
understood
and i felt like i was finally connecting
with people in the way that i wanted to
but a bombshell lawsuit filed earlier
this year by former campers changed all
that alleging a dangerous cycle of
continued sexual abuse and cover-ups by
the non-profit spiritual group that runs
the camp a-r-e the association for
research and enlightenment the first
time i was sexually assaulted by a male
counselor was when i was 13
i was raped and i reported it and i was
silenced and victim blamed
and since then a cascade of new
allegations according to attorney steve
este and so we we realized that the
problem was much bigger than we
initially anticipated initially thought
you started with two people who
represented you represented how many are
there now who are suing i believe we
have 20 um clients are now suing are
based upon their sexual assaults at the
camp
and does that number surprise you 20
yes and no i mean uh when when you
realize that this happened over a period
of years
and you realize that sexual assault's
most unreported crime there is um
you know you realize there's probably a
lot more out there not just 20.
when we first reported on the
allegations the chair of the are group
promised a full investigation
we've been aware of them for 11 months
and we realized pretty early on that we
needed to do a third party investigation
and that's what we have have initiated
and we're
toward the final
stages of the investigation and
we will be making steps to
toward accountability and toward
changing our policies procedures
whatever needs to happen to make this
right but now two former staff members
are coming forward to say senior
management knew a lot more than they are
letting on
karen bolt worked at the are
headquarters in virginia beach virginia
as a long-term employee
i feel that there were many
opportunities
that the administration was given
to prevent actually
some of these incidences from happening
and
all along the way
no one was willing to take
responsibility or accountability
and even after
um it was exposed over a year ago all of
these things that happened
there was still this
denial
there was a lack of urgency
to really find out the truth
tyler dewey worked as a camp counselor
and was one of the first to post
allegations of sexual abuse on a
facebook page
and tyler your own sister says she was
one of the victims of the sexual abuse
and assault that took place at the camp
tell me about that
um well i don't comfortable i don't feel
comfortable going into the details of
the event but um
it followed the same pattern where um a
child was hurt at the camp
and the camp administration didn't
report it to authorities
and didn't encourage
my parents to do that either
um
which continued the culture of putting
the survival of the camp
in front of or before
the um
the needs of children and also
my family was told that we
it was a one-off incident but
after years of working with at the camp
being a camper and then becoming a
counselor and then eventually becoming a
program director at the camp
i noticed the very toxic pattern of
talking to the families and saying this
is you know one-off occurrence when in
fact it was happening you know every
summer or most summers so
it wasn't it was actually systemic in a
pattern
but
um
nobody named it that way and nobody
those who realized it didn't speak up
and those who didn't realize it weren't
able to speak up because they didn't
know it was a pattern
but tyler is also named the lawsuit as
one of the counselors who allegedly was
notified of incidents of sexual abuse
and failed to act on it he denies that
some of the campers who filed the
lawsuit said they felt as if they would
pray for the
older males
what do you make of that allegation
i empathize with them and i i think that
they're right in in many ways i don't
think that all of the men at aire camp
were preying on women
um
and so
i would disagree with uh
all of the men i think there was a
fraction of the men who were predators
and
who were rehired at camp even if
other people reported to management in
the administration that they weren't
safe around them or there was that there
were um there was sexual violence or
sexual harassment
they were rehired even after allegations
were made against them correct many of
them were and that was when that that is
how the issues became
even worse you know
if you want to create an unsafe
environment just re-hire the most unsafe
individuals that come through your door
karen what led to your departure from
ari
um i was
terminated on july 30th
i refused to sign
what i believe
was a gag order and a non-disclosure
agreement
that just so happened to
coincide
with
the lawsuit
and the public knowledge of the lawsuit
the lawsuit cites several camp
activities including what was called the
liberated underwear movement as times
when young campers were groomed for
abuse and was it more than just a uh
liberated movement
um
yes
i would say looking back
it absolutely was
i remember feeling
sexualized and
very uncomfortable with the entire
situation and there were the so-called
massage trains that's hannah as a teen
you had no say in who touched you it was
just you stood behind somebody and
whoever wanted
to would stand behind you
and oftentimes when you are a tall woman
like myself
being hugged by somebody from behind
you're being touched in a place that you
don't want to be touched
which was
oftentimes very uncomfortable for me
there were many activities that they had
that i felt were inappropriate
that could have been seen as something
innocent
but you have to remember that this is an
organization
and the new age
sort of spirituality in general
really
sort of
muddies the boundaries
sometimes with these sort of things in
terms of even personal space
and so as a young child when those lines
are blurred
it's not the child's responsibility to
make sure that they're being protected
it's the adults around them the camp was
shut down for this year and the
executive director of are kevin tadeshi
named in the lawsuit was forced into
early retirement
there's been a change of leadership
supposedly and so if the new leadership
can't come in and make sure the campus
is safe then i i think again it should
shut down
and what is the larger message that
grows out of this case
larger message is that this whenever you
have children in your custody and care
you need to have measures and
preventative measures in place to make
sure they're kept safe uh and when
someone does come forward with with a
report of a sexual assault you need to
take that very very seriously because um
if you don't then it happens it ends up
in a situation like this where it just
happens
year after year after year
attorney steve este told us that he and
a.r.e are now in some of the talks a
spokesman for are would not provide
anybody to appear on our report tonight
and said the group had no comment citing
the pending litigation
coming up next the twisted tragic sega
of the murder family we'll get the
latest from south carolina you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury bonus
well the whole country has been talking
about the bizarre case unfolding in
south carolina involving a prominent
family there the birdhouse
first earlier this summer the mother and
the eldest son were found murdered and
then last week the father was charged
with essentially trying to hire a hitman
to stage his own bot suicide he has
pleaded not guilty and was released on
bond
to learn more about this we're joined in
south carolina by glenn smith of the
posted courier newspaper who is the
editor of the pulitzer prize-winning
watchdog team there and by julie
renneman a former prosecutor trial
lawyer now and analyst for the law and
crime network thank you both for being
here glenn let me start with you what's
the latest in this bizarre case
well as you said brian um alec murdoch
last week was charged with basically
trying to orchestrate his own murder to
cash in on a 10 million dollar life
insurance policy purportedly to help his
son his remaining son
things didn't go well he ended up
admitting to investigators we were told
that this was the case the man they
arrested along with him was a 61 year
old guy who was a former logger who um
murdoch's attorneys have said it was his
primary drug dealer uh so alex turned
himself in last week uh he was released
on a personal recognizance bond he went
back to a drug rehab facility out of
state where he's being treated for an
opioid addiction
and is there seen any connection between
his stage suicide and the murders of his
wife and his eldest son paul
well state investigators aren't saying
right um according to murdoch's
attorneys no they he says that uh alec
regrets that uh this has been a horrible
distraction from uh
police being able to focus on the
murders of paul and maggie back in june
other people you know their suspicions
certainly going around right at the
moment we have six separate
investigations uh swirling around the
murdoch family all sort of coming since
june when the original double homicide
occurred and julian redland how do
prosecutors in this case begin to
unravel the uh twists and turns
there's a lot there's quite a lot of
unraveling keep in mind you know that
this goes back you know when glenn's
talking about you know the various
investigations there's an investigation
with regards to the sun before he was
killed being involved in a boating
accident where he's accused of a young
girl uh dying during perhaps him driving
out when he was uh using alcohol
there's potentially an investigation now
with regards to um the housekeeper who
died several years before in regards to
what they described some type of slip
and fall inside of the home so you know
look the pros no one's saying that
murdog is involved in the murders of his
family but things start to seem a little
strange i think all of us that were
watching when when we heard he was shot
but something does not sound right the
prosecutors are going to be looking at
cell phone records they're going to be
looking at who he spoke to that day and
every other day and they have look they
have a lot of work to do
i don't know how it's going to end um
but we certainly know that he's facing
pretty serious charges albeit white
collar crimes at least at this point and
you never know it may be more in the end
right he's accused of embezzling funds
from his law firm where he's resigned
but julia is a former uh prosecutor a
veteran of this thing how would you
approach uh mr murdoch
well i i mean the question is whether or
not you can ever get him to speak to you
and look i i'm a criminal defense
attorney and if i'm the attorney for uh
mr murdoch i'm going to tell him don't
say a word
you have nothing to gain unless unless
the prosecutor is willing to give you
some level of immunity by the way that's
whether he's guilty of other crimes or
not
you still don't want your client
speaking to them
with that said you know without his help
can they make out the cases against all
the other
other
investigations they may i think one
thing that i'm most interested in
finding out is with regards to the
housekeeper are they going to
bring up the body and is there going to
be an autopsy which by the way my
understanding was never done before
right in fact the cause of death was
listed as natural although supposedly
was an accident glenn smith let me ask
you this what's the reaction uh in south
carolina to this crazy story
uh i think down in uh hampton county the
area where they're from uh it's it's
sort of some some shock and awe that
family has basically um just very
wealthy prominent family that is uh
sort of presided over that county for
generations they have three generations
in the family uh who are the top chief
prosecutor in that area uh 87 years in
total which i'm told is a u.s record i'm
not sure but this is a really powerful
family that uh you know people speak in
hushed tones about and i think they're
pretty shocked by all this and then the
rest of the state i think is is drawn in
and obsessed with the case as everyone
else's
and who's got the lead in terms of the
investigation
the state law enforcement division which
is our state police major uh
police investigation agency
they're working with a couple of local
sheriff's offices we've heard in recent
days that the fbi and department of
justice may be involved in certain
aspects of the case as well
and julie finally let me ask you this
what's it going to take to break this
open what would you be doing if you were
the leading the investigation
look i you know
we don't know if any of these crimes
relate to al murdoch or they relate to
something else i mean there's many
people that say that the death of his
wife and his son has to do with the fact
that the son had been involved in this
boating accident where someone was
killed i don't know if there's a basis
for that or this is purely speculation
there was arguments that there were
death threats made um and so there's so
many different pieces and i assume that
the prosecutors and the investigators
have been working diligently keep in
mind the murders happened several months
ago and so i would assume i would hope
they've gotten somewhere the in the
investigation now whether it points to
the father is being involved or at least
knowing something time will tell
all right well julie rudelman of law and
crime thank you so much and glenn smith
thank you both for being here tonight to
talk to us about this crazy case really
appreciate it
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of media i
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
and time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of video which like the
law and crime trial network is part of
the dan abrams media empire and aiden we
begin with your winner conan o'brien he
didn't win at the emmys but what does
show he put on watch this clip
thank you uh thank you so much um i
think like many of us in this room i was
kind of rooting for conan so this is
bittersweet uh thank you so much conan
for 30 years of inspiring comedy writers
a ridiculous number you're the best
um
thank you
thank you to hbo uh especially kate
he's fine he's fine
he really handed up but i guess it was a
fan favorite although he didn't win
he really was you know uh conan o'brien
was up for one emmy last night uh for
his show conan which had its last season
on tbs uh this year uh he didn't win but
he was still a highlight there was that
moment he got up on stage as well with
stephen colbert and his team to crash
their acceptance speech um he also
trolled the ceo and chairman of the
television academy when he came up to
give his sort of wrote a speech in the
middle of the awards
um conan egged on the crowd to give him
a standing ovation and saluted him uh
throughout the speech um so they were
genuinely funny moments and i don't
think that's usually par for the course
for award shows which can be pretty
unsurprising and contrived um so it was
really it was a good showing from conan
all around
and certainly based on what john oliver
said he was a pioneer in tv late night
comedy that's right yeah and uh you know
we're mourning the death of norm
mcdonald uh this week uh and i urge
everyone to go and watch his appearances
on conan throughout the years because
their conversations the jokes that are
exchanged are really amazing um so it
was good to see conan at the show last
night
now let's get to your loser the tv host
who grew up set when his guest
managed the unpardonable sin of
criticizing donald trump watch this
promise joe i'm gonna joe i'm gonna cut
you i i'm already i'm already weak i'm
already low on time joe joe cut him off
please cut him off now cut them off now
you're not going to blame this on
president trump on my show that's not
happening
all right what was that all about aidan
right so that's grant stinchfield he's a
primetime anchor on newsmax and he's
distinguished himself for some pretty
embarrassing moments uh over the last
year uh since people really started
paying attention to newsmax uh that was
a meltdown that he had last week when he
was hosting an iraq war veteran who was
helping get people out of afghanistan at
the end of the interview the guest made
a comment that was mildly critical of
president donald trump and it prompted
grant to uh you know have this meltdown
because dissent like that is not really
allowed on newsmax particularly from a
host like grant stinchfield um so he
erupted and screamed at his producers to
cut the mic uh of his guest uh he
shouted you're not gonna blame this on
president donald trump um it was
something that i guess made everyone pay
attention to newsmax their ratings have
not been great over the last year is uh
uh their audience has drifted back to
fox news a decent amount um they've made
a big effort to sort of move away from
this impression that they're this sort
of aggressively uh pro-trump news
network that's uh you know not legit um
this is a black eye for them in that
regard
without a doubt all right well quite a
show aidan mclaughlin thank you so much
for being with us and best of the end of
this at medianite and thanks everyone
here for watching our program
great to be with you on law and crime
we'll be back next week thanks to our
staff for getting us on and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you